uh love this guy love this guy love
everything he does and
the uh actor writer producer is now the
host of the audible original podcast the
history
of sketch comedy that he is co-written
um
by the uh the uh he's co-written uh by
his
lovely wife elle who we've gotten a
chance to meet on a couple of occasions
at super bowls
how about that keegan michael key back
on the richardson show how are you
keegan michael key
i'm good sir how are you doing also
don't start don't start with angel heart
yes you just can't start with angel you
know again that's what happened the
other days i've been trying to get my
kids to
to agree to watch the same thing uh the
war with grandpa
was that film the other day and uh it
was
halfway through it i realized i'm like
oh my god this is my kid's introduction
to robert de niro what the hell am i
doing here
you know exactly but yeah i know a
friend of mine
who was in italy once he was watching
star wars and star wars was dubbed
and can you imagine there's an italian
person dubbing
darth vader's voice it's none
i just have to as a caveat this is not
what his voice is supposed to look like
yes
yes the italian james earl jones is not
what we're
well the reason the one of the reasons
why we got on this subject is my kids
dig brain games keegan they do they like
brain
oh my gosh do they love it they can't
get enough of it
so that's great l key produced
television show
there you go that i did not know and and
it's just it's such a it's such a relief
that we can all agree on watching
something that my wife and i
also enjoy too you know that is amazing
it really is that's great
so i'm glad that we could provide that
service for you thank you
i mean that yes that is tough it's a
tough thing because otherwise you're
sitting in the back rolling your eyes
the kids are having time of their lives
but you're like come on
there must be some you know something
equitable that we can do here right
exactly so uh let's get in let's talk a
little bit of the uh the football if you
don't mind to start things off because
uh when when i did meet your your wife
when i did meet elle if i'm not mistaken
she's she loves eli manning right is she
a big elon manning fan is that correct
or am i
ish not really let's put it she's a
giants fan
okay she's a giant so then how does she
how does she enjoy
uh the tom brady-ishness of everything
happening right now
she's not very happy she's not very
happy with the tom bradyishness right of
the of the
of the landscape right now she's a big
mahomes fan she's like mahomes my home's
my home
and i mean now it's interesting because
because with us we um we
we we're big fans of uh gronk we love
gronk
and um we work with gronk and and he's
great but you know
it's uh tom brady is not her she's not
very not a big fan of tom brady is in
the nfc right now
yes she's also a big huge brand so drew
brees and patrick mahomes
are two people that she enjoys watching
very much we'll see
how that turns out ultimately as we come
into the next football season right
um we might she may be watching drew
from a broadcasting box you know but
we'll see
but we'll see yeah she's not she's um
she's not she's yeah tom brady no love
lost there between elky and tom brady
he's finally he's settling family
business again tom brady just when you
thought that he would no longer have uh
much family business
he's settling it again i mean it's and
and and guys he's never beaten before
and brees and rogers and now here comes
mahomes who he has the last time holmes
did not make the super bowls because
brady was standing
in his way i mean it's just unbelievable
what this guy is doing
right it really is i mean listen here's
the thing of course everyone's saying
like him or not he's he's done
he's done as i like to put it he's
lebron did
right i mean lebron you forget the guy's
been to 10
super bowls rich no one's been to 10
super bowls
let alone with two different teams so i
can't i have to give him his props
and there's no there's no way around
that it's really incredible and now
now i do i unlike some people in our
household i have a little bit of love
for tom brady because he's a michigan
man
i can't go against that at growing
growing up in amazing blue neighborhood
and having grown up with one of my best
friends from childhood's brother
being a trainer for beauchembachler
i have to have a little bit of love for
the old number nine you know what i mean
so uh number 10 i'm sorry they're old
number ten yes so there's nothing you
know there's
there's a little bit of love there for
me and and
let alone the accomplishment itself so i
have to ask here uh keegan makoki here
on the rich eyes of joe
when you say trainer for beau
schembeckler for his team or was he
literally
making uh bo do jumping jacks to keep
him in shape like
no he
[Laughter]
i chose jumping jacks specifically
because you know that that seems like
more of a
a bow era type of exercise you know that
rather than the burpee
socks a medicine ball
with a medicine ball a medicine ball
medicine ball
old-fashioned rusty kettlebells uh and
giant
giant ropes giant ropes that we don't
even know what they did
in the gymnasium
boys we're going to the gymnasium he's
wearing a onesie that we saw like from
the world's strongest men
shows on espn2 at four in the morning
you know
you've got to single it on yeah for me
from from athens greece strongest
he's a trainer for bo i'm like okay i
gotta pull on that string a little bit
here
exactly of course you did of course you
did
uh keegan michael key here on the rich
eyes jar i feel like we're coming up uh
with one of the sketches that
you're talking about in your new pod
here the history of sketch comedy what
uh
what attracted you and your your wife to
this subject matter
well way back when when we were starting
to find a way to work with each other
before any of the
the romance blossomed we were we were
working together i was a very
accomplished very brilliant writer and
director and producer
and um we started trying to figure out a
project that we could do together and
when we have this meeting i just want to
make sure some people need to know
that my wife is a good you know guide in
the wool bronx-born
new york jew and she has an encyclopedic
knowledge of jewish jokes
and during that first meeting we talked
she told me a bunch of jokes
and i was laughing up worriously richard
she kind of you know she kind of looked
me sideways and she's like well you are
really finding these jokes funny i said
hey i
i've never heard these jokes i'm a black
kid a black catholic kid
from detroit i don't know these jokes it
lay some more on me
and then as the conversation went on we
found ourselves
analyzing the jokes um breaking them
down talking about what makes them funny
and realize that we have a very similar
sense of humor and
years later you cut to quarantine and
she had this idea and she she said what
you know more about sketch comedy than
anybody i know what if we did
some kind of a book or a podcast or
something about
the history of sketch comedy and we
pitch it to audible
and i remember in the pitch you know
this is you know this is
this is last year this is gosh was march
of last year
and she her pitch was if keegan michael
key
was teaching with guest lecturing at nyu
and was going to do a 10-week series on
the history of sketch comedy
i think it would be a very popular class
i think he'd get a lot of apples at the
end of the day
and and that was the hook and they
bought it and so then we started working
on it
and um she she put it together
she created it and um she kind of put
the format together
and then just gave me gave me an
opportunity to shine and now we're in a
position where we get to share it with
all these other people
so how's the world how far back do you
go like like wait
what do you go we go oh no we go way
back i think
i think a lot of people think we're
gonna start at snl or something we go
back to ancient
samaria like oh no rich
we go to 1900 bc samaria
where literally the first
1900 bc samaria is literally
the first recorded joke
okay what do you mean it's the first
like what what was it like
like uh hold on a second like why does
it why does a i don't even know what the
why is it pterodactyl cross the road i
mean like i mean there's something about
the oxen right yeah
it literally no it's actually a heart
joke it is a part joke
it's something about a young bride
sitting on her husband's lap
and farting and how that is
that is on on board or something
listen it's lost in the context of you
you're gonna be like wait for is that a
way homer is that did you get it on the
way home
[Laughter]
on the way back in your chariot you're
gonna get oh
yeah she was on his lap so literally i
think
it's so funny because in the series we
even talked about we go hey isn't that
funny
the people who came to us with the wheel
and written language
all folk also came up with the fort joke
what does that say about the human race
that the first joke was a fart joke
you know i guess it just stands the test
of time
it's just never not funny so we
literally start i mean there's a there's
a whole half a chapter about cavemen
and our suppositions about what we think
cavemen found funny and how they
communicated that to each other
and we go all the way from you know we
so we literally go from neanderthals
to to um to you know to trump jokes on
snl
and so it's it's the whole gamble we run
the gamut of history
yeah so you know sumerians greeks
medieval times
the the the 15th century um um then the
the
the advent of vaudeville we do the whole
thing sure keegan michael key here
along with his wife elle um the audible
original podcast
the history of sketch comedy i could
talk about this all day so like what
would be
the uh advent on television your show of
shows would that be the first
version of this we do we dive into your
show of show shows and milton berle
and there's really fun interesting
factoids that we
that we that we found in the research
like milton berle
the um people found out that when the
milton berle show when the texaco comedy
hour started
when that show when he was hosting that
show they were rotating hosts and then
eventually it just became milky uncle
milty
and what would happen is right after the
show was over
you could see across the country that
there'd be a huge deluge of water usage
because everybody got up from their sets
and went to the bathroom
because they didn't want to miss a
minute of milton brewer's show rich
when milton brown i'm getting the
numbers wrong but um
it was crazy like there were there was
something like
75 000 television sets 75 000 television
sets in america
and then within two years when milton
bros on tv
it was 750 000 television sets
like i i can't even fathom it that's
just
like that's there's no stop that's star
power
and so we really we really delve into
that and to him
um martin lewis colgate comedy hour
jackie gleason
bob hope so we do everything and then
caliber net show obviously that's got to
be included in that
snl carol burnett showed me the variety
era that that
horrible awful garish variety area with
donnie and marie
and remember hey taylor hello
did you know all that confetti rip
taylor fantastic with his
bucket of confetti oh my god
that is a name i have not heard in
forever right you haven't heard
i mean flowers and madame adam of course
well i mean well when when you would
select them for the block on hollywood
squares is a big moment for me as a
child watching television
me as well and you know
you know paul lind would say you know so
i love it paul then but just be laughing
through the entire thing
yes because you could say you know a lot
of those game shows in the hollywood
squares and match game that was some
scripted comedy as well i mean we could
really go
deep into this whole thing and uh man i
love this what a brilliant idea what a
brilliant brilliant idea what
would you say by the way first of all
very thankful that that was the research
on milton berle that you mentioned
um wow secondly
secondly um
oh man that [ __ ] now that just shows
how much you are a comedy baby okay
thank you
thank you sir i'm showing off my bona
fides here i'm flexing my
comedy muscles all right second and
secondly
okay now would you say that the sketch
comedy
is funnier when the uh the actor or
actress
breaks and laughs in the middle of it
what do you think
it is funnier it it's a little bit of a
cheat
but it's always funnier because what
here's the thing about comedy comedy's
about social more race
right like you know when we see a nice
beautiful form tackle
and the legs get taken out the guy goes
down and you're like what well done good
tackle
and then when you see someone fly
through the air and just shiver a dude
in the neck
like dick night train lane from the 50s
and you're going
whoa well that's illegal
like benny blade back in the old days
with my detroit lions
and so what happens is the equivalent to
that sketch comedy
is that you you especially in snl it's
so titillating because you know it's
live
and you know they're trying to navigate
this entire evening
and so part of you is going are they
going to mess up it's a lot like the
circus right like the trapeze artist
what makes us laugh it gets funnier
because the stakes are so high and then
people just go
forget it and they start giggling or
they can't help themselves from giggling
it is infectious
it makes us laugh more because our
expectation is they're going to make it
all the way through the sketch right
like carol burnett there's some
extremely funny carol burnette sketches
oh yeah that you just laughed because
the writing's terrific
but when you see harvey corbin start to
grin
there's really nothing better no i know
anyone needs to look up the dentist
sketch
with tim conway and him from that um
even the
famed cowbell sketch with christopher
walken
on saturday night live when well i think
is it
fallon breaks during it at one point i
mean i i love that
and i know that that's technically not
what you're supposed to do
but i i love it i just love it it is
funnier
i mean then the opposite of course is
the sweaty ball
sketch with
how are they doing this how are they
they're super human comedians
how are they doing this it's like it's
too good it's like too good
like i said i couldn't i could talk
about this all day but uh you know um
i appreciate the call uh keegan it's i i
do miss uh
chatting with you and look you know um i
i can't wait to i'm assuming you
might not be going to the super bowl
this year i know you go every year unl
have been going
quite a bit um next year here in los
angeles
i know we don't take it for granted we
don't take it but this time around we
definitely won't take it for granted
when i see you next to the game right
big time that's absolutely right i look
forward to seeing you richard thanks so
much for having me on oh gosh
and she says hello please send my best
um yeah i know
look i'm a i'm a jew born in brooklyn
raised in staten island you know your
your wife had made hello when we first
met at the super bowl you know
talking sports and whatever it was
phenomenal just great so
um you're gonna love this series rich
you're gonna love this here it's great i
can't get enough of it and again it's on
audible the audible original podcast the
history of sketch comedy
take care of yourself keegan michael
keith thanks for the call anytime you
too buddy right back at you there we go
okay
keegan m key on twitter at
keeganmichaelkey on instagram
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here